esta es sana vive en un tranquilo barrio
a 75 kilómetros al oeste de quien dice
que el 7 de marzo soldados rusos la
violaron su nombre ha sido cambiado y su
rostro difuminado para proteger su
identidad como técnica de oro es por
esto un soldado entró en nuestra casa mi
marido y yo estábamos ahí a punta de
pistola me llevó a una casa vecina me
ordenó quítate la ropa o te dispararé
luego empezó a violarme
anna dice que su agresor era un soldado
checheno cuatro tropas rusas entraron
mientras la violaba y se lo llevaron
cuando las tropas salieron de su casa
anna encontró viagra
se drogaban y se emborrachaban la
mayoría de los soldados invasores son
asesinos violadores y saqueadores
justo al final de la calle dejan a su
vecino dijo que el mismo soldado
checheno vio la otra mujer dentro de la
casa se dejó esta nota en un espejo
escrita con lápiz de labios dice
torturada por desconocidos enterrada por
soldados rusos la historia de anna es
uno de los muchos ejemplos de
violaciones que se están denunciando
tras la retirada de rusia de las zonas
cercanas a kiev la defensora del pueblo
ucraniano para los derechos humanos y la
presidenta de la organización de
derechos humanos la strada afirman haber
documentado varios casos de violación
queremos que escuchen nuestras voces que
la violencia y la violación son
utilizadas ahora como arma de guerra por
los invasores rusos en ucrania la
prioridad por ahora es dar apoyo a la
superviviente la directora de la agencia
de la onu para la mujer ha pedido una
investigación independiente sobre todas
las denuncias de violación y violencia
sexual